Now, there comes a point in every game developments life where content
creators, artists and designers, become very frustrated with the engineers on a
project. You see, most novice engineers for game dev, when adding artwork and
content into a game, will usually hard code the path references to assets.
Which means that if a designer or artist, wants to change that data, they have
to go talk to an engineer first. Which, engineers usually have a back-log of
30-60 days worth of tasks, kind of slowing down the entire project. More
experienced engineers know how to avoid this and actually move themselves
towards a concept of data driven design. A concept which allows non-engineers
to effectively change the execution of the flow and the assets in the game
without ever having to talk to an engineer. Basically this works by providing
some sort of simplistic data file outside of the game code, a text file, XML,
JSON. Something that the designers and the artists can quickly iterate on
without having to talk to anybody in the pit. Case in point, let's say a
designer and an artist need to find the optimal animation time for some kick
maneuver on a 2D fighting game. Well, it'd be great if they could actually sit
at the desk and try different variations of art creation and timing without
actually having to go talk to an engineer to change the frames that are
referenced. Most games these days actually have a huge backbone of data-driven
design. Of course, you end up in a very, very weird position is that if you
have too much data driven design you actually become a slave to it, in the
sense that most of your code exists out there. So changing small situations
becomes very, very difficult, and you actually have to bring an engineer back
in. So walk that line very finely. You want to be just data driven enough that
it makes sense and everyone can get their job done, but not so much that it
actually causes problems to your larger architecture.